[Music]
do you guys like to karaoke
[Music]
how about video key oh wait
like tik tok yeah is it like dubsmash
oh yes hips hips elbows then
you got to end it with your right
oh yeah i finally did it no i didn't
want to okay anyway so
video key and karaoke are pretty
practically the same thing
but i just discovered what it was from
this article which
videokey apparently is when you're being
recorded as
you perform
oh it's karaoke oh my god video they're
being recorded
it's like karaoke with the fbi those
drunk ig stories here's what this is
singing at the gas station bro you ever
done
karaoke with a live band oh my god
[ __ ] what are you doing claire yeah
where the [ __ ] is that a rich guy
amsterdam or something no there's
literally a bar in
it might even be k-town-ish there's a
band and they have a list of songs and
the band knows all the songs and it's
like a regular karaoke [ __ ] but you pick
i did some [ __ ] in sync and it's a
live band they play with it
but do they have like my neck my back do
they have my neck my back
maybe my [ __ ] and my crap
break it down so that was video
video what is your videography i like
videography
video cream what oh my god what's so
hard for me video
pokey okay can we go
i don't know what what about it it's
corrupt
korean that's the besides the point so
in the philippines in manila of course
oh the capital of karaoke capital
karaoke
so in manila recently the mayor
announced
that daytime karaoke is banned what
but only night time only nighttime it's
like footloose
yeah for real dancing's illegal wait
daytime karaoke is banned yeah so
between the hours of 7am to 5pm from
monday to saturday you
are no longer allowed but you guys never
had filipino neighbors though
it's loud dude the whole country is
probably singing
all damn days so they're gonna be like
excuse me you have to turn it up
you get at work imagine they have
something like the purge we're only one
day out of the year karaoke
i think it's that karaoke machine that
they have
super loud with the crazy echo yeah and
they're just like
we cannot do that anymore it's too many
microphones going off at the same time
too much feedback can you keep the
reverb under control please
i actually have one of those karaoke
microphones cool with bluetooth and you
can do the whole thing it's just a
microphone i just take it to like trader
joe's
how does it make you sound better when
the echo is so strong
i don't know the reverb that goes over
there the reaper
almost like covers up the bad sounds
like
for sure for what occasion just like
every occasion
everybody trader joe's a cake trader
joe's right you're right you're right
right
i put out my hat you know yeah in aisle
three
um but they smell the hat and they're
like oh god they smell the hat
no then they give her more money yeah
like she needs it she needs them
i'll never forget yeah so violators of
the ordinance will be subjected to
a fine of 1 000 php which is about 20 us
dollars
oh the first violation for the second
it's 2 000
which is 41 and then the third one is 3
000 which is 62
i told you not to sing see if i can't
hold it it's who i am
if you're real ballin you would just go
there and say [ __ ] the police yeah
i think i might sing all day back to
police
[Laughter]
so the reason for this is because the
mayor
has just received they've been they've
just received so
many complaints from parents that
karaoke activities are
disrupting students during their online
classes
the whole neighborhood is probably
singing all day yeah they have nothing
else to do this is seriously like one of
those
movies where like uh you know the
sunshine is taken away or like you know
and then they have to get it back
and i don't know we just let's pitch it
the whole country can't sing anymore
right right right i like the purge idea
though that's what i'm saying one night
everyone's like get ready it's almost
karaoke night
what a happy country where that's the
problem right everyone's singing
facts oh that's such a positive way
because then
like you know but then you forget about
like the the
the war on the drug criminals and how
they're killing them and stuff
don't want to hear it we're talking
about singing filipinos
positive stuff yeah yeah yeah that's
cool yeah but they have i mean they have
a mango problem you heard about that the
filipinos what is it okay so what's
happening is
they're like in the state of emergency
because the mangoes they overproduced it
and usually they're able to sell the
exports because of corona
they're like we have too many mangoes i
don't know what to do tim has too many
mangoes too
i do have too many mangoes yeah i have a
mango tree no it's my mom
every time we go over there for dinner
side note guys
every time we go to my family's house
for dinner since she was pregnant now my
parents give us like a bunch of food to
take home
and it's always a [ __ ] crate of
mangoes oh my goodness
is that good for pregnancy apparently
they're good for pregnancy so my mom
always gives us a bunch of bananas
mangoes
oh yeah yeah
it's always like plantains [ __ ]
a bunch of have you guys had the small
bananas the sweet ones yeah those are
good
are those not plantains no plantains are
huge plantains are long
and then you cook them all the tiny ones
we're playing now you got to cook them
so my mom you know she gives us those to
cook even though we never do
sorry mom and um and then like she gives
us those small bananas which are super
sweet oh they're so good they taste like
[ __ ] apple grape banana i need
i need everything you're saying i'm so
hungry i'm so hungry they're not they're
not letting me eat now i'm just gonna
help help and then it's like
all these mangoes oh my little mommy
little toast have you ever had these oh
i'm not sure i feel like i have because
i thought this suspended this whole time
i've just only had coz i've never seen
them raw do you think the bigger bananas
punk them at the supermarket
no but here's the thing now i really
want to make this filipino movie of like
everyone like there's really some [ __ ]
going down like that
is corrupt but then they sing because
everyone's delusional and they're
in denial
he looks familiar that green dick
you bill i [ __ ] some green dicks in my
day
kermit the frog call me miss piggy honey
because i [ __ ] the green dick
i'm like you should get checked yeah
that's uh that's uh gonorrhea no wait no
uh what is it that has the leprosy
the clap that yeah the green green
discharge
one of them one of them has green
discharge it might be chlamydia
gonorrhea oh no are you looking at us oh
i'm so curious
i don't even want to look at stds no
don't show us the pictures
we're just about to have lunch well hold
on uh out of penis
somehow this will make me hungrier oh i
think it's out of the way
out of vagina i think it's a female
what does it mean when you have green
districts i love that song by the way
it's actually thank you thank you
i don't know oh oh so you're like
actually good at stuff i am
actually you got you have talents how
did you do that
kazoos aren't because these are really
easy oh you just are secrets we don't
tell them
you control your own throat because
these are literally just you going to do
it
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry he's like
going like
i like how you're playing the piano
thing at first and she never mentioned
[Laughter]
yeah i don't know if i could like live a
life without
uh singing
more what is this the rose parade i was
actually in the rose parade you were
i was in 2004 i played the clarinet for
our
high school marching band but i faked it
like half the time
yeah there's so many people you're just
like
i'm doing the wrong i have the clarinet
like this impression
repeat these clarinet skills man no
legit it was like
because half the time there's so many
people i kind of just joined on the whim
because i just felt like joining
something
um and and uh i would just sit there and
i would
truly be pretending half the time you're
just like [ __ ] i didn't practice and he
just marching
i knew maybe some of the songs
yeah exactly exactly that's a really
good impression of me
um but i was thinking half the time
which is life
which is your yeah your love life yeah
that's how i sing in the car i only sing
the
the chorus and then when the verse comes
out i'm like
[Music]
yeah everyone's like what's this
i was gonna say when like you're singing
really loud and like the [ __ ] song
cuts off like a second and you have to
hear your own voice all shitty but
low-key though and
we've also talked about this too of like
we know that we're good singers like we
know that we can put it down but when
you're on the spot like
actually like you get anxiety your
throat
you don't want to actually it's almost
like embarrassing if people think that
you think
you're good yeah yeah your confidence in
your own singing is embarrassing
yes why like everyone except filipinos
because they all are good they are good
they're so [ __ ] good using their
skills at the character all the time
because they might be discovered
oh maybe this is what this is good for
the rest of the world now that filipinos
can't practice
no we have a chance it levels the planet
yeah
the thai community the chinese community
we can finally
like thrive in karaoke crazy about songs
when you're seeing it by yourself the
song's not that hard right but then now
you got to sing that song where someone
else becomes ten times harder
dude it's like you forget all the lyrics
you're like how did it get so hard all
of a sudden
what's your favorite song to sing when
when you want to like flex
i can't not okay not not gonna lie
when i hit the karaoke i hit some usher
nice and slow
and if i like copy his voice just right
and one time j.r aquino was there at a
karaoke bar with me
harmonizing with me oh my god this [ __ ]
was so fire bro was it on video was it
on video no
yeah but it was great you don't get
[ __ ] up with this harmony you start
seeing what he's singing no no no
god always
yeah he'll just match you whatever's
happening right wait wait wait wait
trying to match him and then does he go
up an octave
well i mean of course i was drinking oh
so then do you really know how good it
was it was great
mine is mine is weak swb ah
oh that's a good one i thought you're
gonna say you're you're i'm weak bro
yeah that one is strong true the sw
swb weak that's a good one because it's
not that
you know right it's like a good because
mine is already low my voice is pretty
like
very except when they [ __ ] key change
bro and they take it up
yeah you gotta sing some brandy then she
got a deep voice have you ever [ __ ]
oh yeah have you ever oh brian mcknight
any time
well he got a high voice though that
second verse though oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah he gets really i can get down
sometimes like i'll be in an audition
and like they've oh we're done we're
done with this
[Music]
you